hi I'm Adam Scott and I am going
undercover on the Internet
this is actually me Twitter from Kendall
at a be one month know at role for salsa
worse
who hurt Adams got so much he felt the
need to grow that mustache is he okay uh
yeah I like a mustache it's pretentious
sure hipstery fine I'm too old to care
his Adam Scott's beard returning for big
little eyes season two you would have to
ask him I have no clue Yahoo Answers was
Adam Scott really in gym on G and The
Truman Show I looked him up on iTunes it
said under movies her is in was Jumanji
and The Truman Show
I don't star star star star believe it
well listen I'm not in either of those
movies so yeah you really shouldn't star
star star star believe it posted do you
think Adam Scott and Anna Kendrick could
pull off being siblings
look at those mouths is it the mouths
that do it I always thought it was like
our similar eyebrows or something ready
if the good place is set in the same
universe as Parks and Rec and trevor is
portrayed by Adam Scott could that mean
that then from Parks and Rec is dead
[Music]
sure pora where can I get the jacket
Adam Scott wears on Parks and Recreation
I were a series of jackets so I'm not
exactly sure
next is Adam Scott actor like there
hated by the people I don't know but now
that you asked I'm starting to question
how did Adam Scott land the role of Ben
in parks and recreation well I
originally auditioned for the pilot of
Parks and Recreation I was probably too
excited because I was a huge fan of the
office of course I remember getting the
audition and just working so hard on it
overcooking it and getting in there and
just being stiff and not funny after not
getting that my friends called and said
you want to do this party down thing
we're doing and so I got to go do that
show and then because of party down Mike
Schur called me again like a year and a
half later and invited me to join Parks
and Rec so it was weirdly all worked out
YouTube I think my kids were kind of
like
he looks like the kid from Jumanji when
the kid cheats and turns into a monkey
from the book or the movie I don't know
Wikipedia early life Scott was born in
Santa Cruz California the son of an and
knee court court court era yeah that's
that's my my mom's name is an A & E but
her maiden name was quarter ro which is
quar t AR AR fo not sure what what this
one is and Douglas Scott my dad's name
is actually Dugald i think Dugald scott
is the most Scottish name possible I
don't think you could get more Scottish
than Dugald Scott he is one-quarter
Sicilian on his mother's side how do
they know this he has two older siblings
Shannon and David very true Scott has
said that David looks like me but is far
more cerebral and inherited the
intellect of our parents that's a really
sweet thing for me to say more twitter
is that Adam Scott's real singing voice
in big little lies in the finale because
I thought it would be much much deeper
it was not me singing I wish I could
sing I like that fella saying I should
you mean to tell me mr. Adam Scott you
were on Boy Meets World
well son of a Topanga slapped me
sideways and call me Grif that's that's
fine one of my first Jobs was was Boy
Meets World I first played teen with
guitar and then like a year later I
played Grif for three episodes three
episodes and I get asked about it like
every day or Korra who is the best Adam
Scott the golfer or the actor I'm gonna
say the golfer I think that he's
probably kind of all-around just a bit
better is that guy Adam Scott Ashton
Kutcher's brother I feel like that is
news that would have been out by now had
it been true what if right now is like
yeah
you know where that's my brother we we
grew up together it's my brother
submitted more Yahoo Answers what is the
height and weight of actor Adam Scott
I'm five foot nine and weigh 150 pounds
I want to know what weight to get to so
I can look like him God he must drive
the women crazy good lord
I'm 510 but but I'm not exactly sure how
much I weigh and I do not drive the
women crazy it's just not something that
happens you know this was fun I am a
different person now I shed three skins
not literally like spiritually now when
I close the computer what we all
everyone going to cease to exist okay
it's all gonna black out as soon as I
close this it's all over